queremos encontrar la masa de un átomo
de carbono 12 y si recuerdas en las
clases de química poníamos las cosas en
una balanza entonces en este vídeo usa
tu imaginación y vamos a suponer que
podemos tomar un átomo de carbono y lo
ponemos en esta pequeña balanza que
estoy dibujando entonces tienes esta
pequeña balanza que nos va a
proporcionar la masa de nuestro átomo de
carbono 12 y normalmente en química
solemos usar gramos como nuestra unidad
de medida entonces tú puedes imaginar
que aquí te da un peso en gramos y como
los átomos son extremadamente pequeños
este número será extremadamente pequeño
y es frustrante trabajar con números
pequeños así que en lugar de trabajar
con números extremadamente pequeños los
químicos inventaron el término llamado
unidad de masa atómica así que la unidad
de masa atómica lo cual abre veamos de
la siguiente forma y emea
así se abrevia unidad de masa atómica
muy bien ahora los
nos tomaron la masa de un átomo de
carbono 12 como la definición de que un
átomo de carbono 12 es igual a 12
m y todo lo demás es relativo a este
valor ahora sólo para darte una idea de
la masa de una unidad de masa atómica
una m es igual a 1.660 539 por 10 a la
menos 24 gramos
entonces si tú quieres conocer la masa
del átomo de carbono 12 en gramos un
átomo de carbono 12 es igual a 12 m
y un un es igual a esta cantidad en
gramos
entonces si multiplicas este número de
la derecha por 12 lo que obtienes es la
masa de un átomo de carbono 12 en gramos
pero es un número muy pequeño entonces
resulta más sencillo usar esta
definición un átomo de carbono 12 tiene
una masa de 12
y si observas esto que es lo que
encontrarás en la tabla periódica
este número es la masa atómica del
carbono pero nota que no es exactamente
12 um porque observa que este número si
es exactamente 12 un 12.000 0 y así
sigue es exactamente 12 pero este no es
exactamente 12 es 12.01 de dónde viene
el punto 0 1 sucede que la definición de
masa atómica incluye la masa promedio de
todos los isótopos de un elemento aquí
solamente estamos hablando del carbono
12 pero existen más isótopos de carbono
y la definición de masa atómica es la
masa promedio de todos los isótopos de
un elemento es a lo que se refiere este
número de aquí entonces veamos veamos
como podemos calcular este número que
vemos en la tabla periódica pero
calcularlo para diferentes elementos
ahora antes de hacerlo para el carbono
hagamos un ejemplo donde vemos el
cálculo para una calificación de una
clase
porque una calificación se puede ver
como un promedio ponderado y es con lo
que estamos trabajando así que digamos
que tu profesor da más calificación a
los exámenes que las tareas el 70% de la
calificación total está dado por los
exámenes y el 30% de la calificación
total está dado por las tareas así que
70% más 30% eso da un total de 100% el
100% de tu calificación muy bien ahora
digamos que eres un buen estudiante y
que promedia hasta un 90 en todos tus
exámenes y que siempre hace esta tarea
así que tienes 100 en tu tarea entonces
cuál es tu calificación final lo que
haremos primero es convertir el
porcentaje a decimal entonces 70% esto
es un cálculo simple pero aún así voy a
usar la calculadora
entonces tenemos tenemos 70
entre sí en esto te da el decimal que
buscas punto 7 así que lo escribimos
tenemos aquí entonces punto 7 y ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es mover el punto
decimal si estamos dividiendo entre 100
9 es el punto decimal una dos veces para
que te dé punto 7 así que punto 7 por 90
esto a que es igual usamos la
calculadora entonces la respuesta punto
7 la multiplicamos por 90 es igual a 63
muy bien así que esto es igual a 63
ahora hagamos lo mismo pero para la
tarea vamos a convertir el porcentaje a
decimal entonces movemos el decimal dos
unidades hacia la izquierda tenemos
puntos 3.3 lo multiplicamos por 100
punto 3 por 100
esto es igual este cálculo es sencillo
esto es igual a 30 y para saber cuál es
tu calificación final en la clase
simplemente suma
estos dos números 63 + 30 te dan 93 su
calificación en esa materia fue de 93 y
este es un cálculo que tiene sentido
porque tus exámenes valen más que tus
tareas entonces tu calificación final
estará más cercano a la cantidad de la
calificación que obtuviste en tus
exámenes está más cercano a 90 que a 100
y esta es la idea del promedio ponderado
muy bien ahora hagamos exactamente lo
mismo pero esta vez hablemos de carbonos
así que bueno veamos aquí tenemos estos
dos números para carbono
tenemos dos isótopos diferentes de
carbono tenemos el carbono 12 y tenemos
el carbono 13 ahora casi todo átomo de
carbono en el mundo es uno de estos dos
isótopos y no estoy tan interesado en
digamos el carbono 14 porque se
encuentra en cantidades extremadamente
pequeñas ahora si tomas estos números
aproximados 98 puntos 89 por ciento de
los átomos de carbono en el mundo son
carbono 12 y 1.1 10 por ciento de los
átomos de carbono
son carbono 13 ahora si tú sumas todo
esto debes obtener 100% así que esto
representa el 100% de los átomos de
carbono y por definición el carbono 12
tiene una masa atómica de 12 m
experimentando puedes darte cuenta que
el carbono 13 tiene una masa de 13 m
entonces recuerda la diferencia entre
carbono 12 y carbono 13 el carbono 13
tiene un neutrón más a eso es a lo que
se refiere ese 13 el carbono 13 tiene un
neutro más que el carbono 12 y nota que
le sucedió a la masa la masa aumentó de
12 a aproximadamente 13 entonces puedes
ver de inmediato que un neutrón tiene
aproximadamente la masa de un m
aunque debes tener en cuenta que estos
números no son exactos pero sólo para
darte una idea de que agregar un neutrón
hace que tu isótopo tenga más masa
haremos exactamente lo mismo que hicimos
con las calificaciones haremos un
cálculo para obtener el promedio
ponderado y lo primero que necesitamos
hacer es convertir nuestros porcentajes
en fracciones entonces solamente vamos a
mover el punto decimal dos espacios
hacia la izquierda así que tenemos punto
9 889 y eso lo vamos a multiplicar por
12 lo cual es la masa del isótopo de
carbono 12 entonces punto 9 889 por 12
voy a sacar la calculadora
aquí está entonces hacemos el cálculo
punto 9 889 por 12 esto es igual a 11.8
668 diremos que esto es igual a 11.867
lo escribo haremos lo mismo pero para el
carbono 13 necesitamos mover el punto
decimal dos unidades a la izquierda así
que los movemos 12 y tenemos puntos 0 11
10 x 13.00 34 esto es igual a vamos a
usar la calculadora entonces punto 0 11
10 por 13.000 34 y obtenemos punto 14 43
así que esto es igual a punto 14 43 muy
bien y ya con estos cálculos lo que
haremos es sumar estos dos números
entonces vamos a sumar estos dos números
sumemos este con este número muy bien
así que sacó la calculadora
bueno ya tenemos el 0.14 43 a este
número le vamos a sumar el 11.867 muy
bien es igual a 12.0 11 así que lo
escribo entonces la suma de estos dos es
igual a 12.0 11 muy bien entonces note
que este número que obtuvimos está mucho
más cercano a 12 que a 13 y eso ocurre
porque la mayoría de los átomos son de
carbono 12 entonces esto es un promedio
ponderado así que 12.01 de hecho lo
vimos este este número al inicio del
vídeo recuerdas aquí esta es lo que
veríamos en la tabla periódica para el
carbono aquí está el número
12.01 es un promedio ponderado se
refiere a la masa promedio de todos los
isótopos de un elemento
estarás utilizando este número mucho en
la tabla periódica así que recuérdalo